welcome to another Q&A episode of the
stronger by science podcast in today's
episode Greg and I field listener
questions about electro my assimilation
the effects of alcohol consumption on
body composition fruit consumption
during weight loss weight lifting shoes
for squatting overrated and underrated
exercises and much more remember if you
want your questions answered on a future
episode you can submit those questions
using the links that are available in
the episode description as always thank
you for listening and enjoy the episode
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast on this Q&A episode we are gonna
get right into business so the first
question is for Greg the question is
from Jesse Armstrong coy how do you
think you say that I think that's
probably close enough close enough I
mispronounce all the names so it feel
weird to start getting them right now
I've got such a long track record of
getting every name room it's like that
key and peele sketch it is getting a a
Ron it is basically getting to that that
stage right now okay so the question is
do you think there's any purpose to
including EMS in your training for
strength or muscle hypertrophy would it
be useful on top of your normal training
and if so how would you use it to
produce the best results yes so for
people listening who don't know what EMS
is it stands for electro my esteem
ulation basically you're hooking
electrodes up to your muscles and you
have a machine that runs a current into
those electrodes to stimulate your
muscles to make them contract EMS is
frequently used in rehab settings but
there there are some people who think
that it can be useful for primarily
strength development I haven't seen as
many people promote it for hypertrophy
but anyway so I want to be transparent
about the fact that I have no practical
experience with EMS it's some
that interests me a little bit but it
doesn't interest me enough to actually
drop money to to buy an EMS unit but
what I will say is in 2011-2012 there
were a couple systematic reviews
published by Filipovic and colleagues in
the journal strength and conditioning
research one of them was just about the
EMS parameters that would help one
elicit the largest adaptations if they
wanted to use EMS for strength and power
development so I'm not gonna recap that
will link it in the show notes if you
want to use EMS that systematic review
would probably provide you with with a
useful guide for the machine settings
that you would use the one the other
systematic review was looking at like
the actual adaptations seen with EMS
stimulation in trained and elite
athletes and what I'll say is that I
don't necessarily trust the results of
this systematic review and meta-analysis
simply because so either EMS is the best
training modality modality on the planet
and everyone to this point has been
overlooking it in spite of the fact that
there's you know pretty much any team in
a high performance setting will probably
have an EMS unit but in spite of that
they've completely missed it as just a
total godsend for strength and power
development or the studies that fed into
this systematic review and meta-analysis
have some sort of systematic bias where
they're reporting outrageously large
effects so what do I mean by that in
three to six weeks of stimulation we're
talking about in trained athletes
isometric max force increasing by
sixty to eighty percent
eccentric max force increasing by around
forty percent or so rate of force
development increasing by about seventy
five percent
vertical jump height increasing by up to
25 percent sprint times decreasing by
close to five percent so I mean the
thing is if like those are all those
would all be pretty impressive changes
for completely untrained athletes to see
changes at large in trained and elite
athletes you don't come across that
every day and so I I understand that
this isn't the most rigorous argument
but I kind of feel like if EMS worked
this well due to the fact that it is
already pretty ubiquitous and
high-performance settings you would kind
of think that everyone would just be
using it a lot already and talking to
sports coaches who coach either
collegiate athletes or professional
athletes it doesn't seem like EMS is
something that they lean on super hard
as a training modality which makes me
think that the actual size of the
benefits one would expect to get in the
real world are probably considerably
smaller than than what's being reported
in this meta-analysis so I could be
completely wrong about that it like EMS
could be the thing that everyone is
overlooking that could give you a huge
leg up on the competition I'm just a
little bit skeptical that that is the
case what do you think Eric yeah I mean
I agree you look at the just the
percentage changes in that meta-analysis
they seem pretty pretty wild and I feel
like if there were interventions out
there that were affecting those outcomes
to that magnitude it would be it
wouldn't be the exception it would be
the rule it's like are we gonna train on
top of on top of this EMS it's like yeah
those effects are that big
so yeah I mean I just that the thing
that I'll admit I've never read a lot of
the EMS literature because I've always
it's never been my research focus and in
terms of practical application it's
always seemed to me like a remarkably
impractical thing to apply generally
speaking so I haven't looked into it a
ton personally but I I agree with your
interpret interpret ation of that
meta-analysis and I just don't think
there's much there especially for the
general lifter who's not in it like a
professional setting where they have
access to all sorts of equipment like
that yeah I agree
well of course I agree because you just
restated what I said
good job only you're here then that's
great sure sounds good okay for Eric
what are the effects of alcohol
consumption on body composition is fat
loss effected or compromised for guard
--less of being in a caloric deficit and
that's from JP close so this one it's a
topic near and dear to my heart I
responsibly enjoy a beverage from time
to time big fan of IPAs and bourbon Greg
what are you drinking lately not much
honestly
generally a quad guy you like the sweet
Belgian beers I've been into a New
England style IPAs recently okay so the
question is are indulgences in these
delicious beverages what are they gonna
do to us in terms of our gains now I
want to preface this by saying if you're
in a caloric deficit and you have some
your calories coming from alcohol you're
still going to lose weight and that's so
that if that's what you're worried about
to the person asking the question you
can absolutely still lose weight and
create a caloric deficit with alcohol in
the diet now obviously when we talk
about creating a caloric deficit we're
not just talking about total calories we
get more specific and talk about how
much protein should I have how much
carbohydrate so when we talk about
setting your macro
we often talk about protein carbohydrate
and fat sometimes fiber gets mentioned
it should get mentioned we rarely talk
about alcohol cuz I think the default
assumption is that alcohol is not going
to be a major contributor to your macros
but it is a macronutrient that
contributes seven calories per gram on a
practical note when my clients ingest
alcohol when they're tracking I
encourage them to just count all of the
calories as carbohydrate because I never
like to have alcohol taking away from
fat or protein in the diet but now down
to business of what it's actually doing
there's quite a bit of evidence showing
that excessive intakes of alcohol or
high intakes of alcohol are not great on
the muscle end of body composition so
there's a good review by Kimball and
lang in 2018 that talks about all of the
kind of molecular mechanisms by which
alcohol affects muscle so we know that
alcohol decreases the activity of the
mTOR signaling pathway which is really
important for skeletal muscle
development and maintenance and that has
a bunch of effects on all these
different downstream protein targets
that are really involved in the building
and maintenance of skeletal muscle
tissue they also mentioned the review
something that they call leucine
resistance that a given amount of
dietary leucine in the context of high
alcohol high alcohol intake does not
seem to elicit the same response in
terms of protein synthesis so there's
the muscle and there's also the
endocrine side of things so a lot of
hormones are affected by again we're
talking relatively high alcohol intakes
so we see things like increases in
catecholamines increases in cortisol
increases in estrogen reductions in
human growth hormone and testosterone so
a lot of endocrine changes that you
probably weren't hoping for to summarize
it and put it in a nutshell so I think
it's quite intuitive and and anyone
asking the question already knew that
having really a really high proportion
of your calories coming from
alcohol is a bad idea whether you're in
a deficit or not between the muscle
effects and the endocrine effects it is
not conducive to optimizing body
composition so theoretically you can
have a whole bunch of alcohol in the
diet still be in a deficit I guess and
you could still lose weight in that
context but the quality of weight loss
would probably be pretty garbage you'd
probably be losing a lot more lean mass
than you'd like and not as much fat as
you'd like and then there's also the
obvious health effects of that as well
if you have limited calories and a whole
bunch of them are coming from alcohol
you are probably missing out on a lot of
things in the diet so in in the reviews
that you see on alcohol a lot of times
they'll say to keep your alcohol dose if
you're interested in body composition
and performance outcomes to keep your
your alcohol dose for a given day under
0.5 grams per kilogram about there is
kind of the upper limit where they're
like if you're there you should be
totally fine one unit of alcohol I
looked this up one unit I guess is
technically eight grams I actually
thought it was higher than that but but
that's when I was seeing but apparently
most drinks actually contain one to
three technical units of alcohol so the
moral of the story there is if you're
having you know a couple drinks you're
probably fine and even on a deficit it
shouldn't be super problematic to fit a
drink or two into your macros and still
have completely fine success with your
your bodybuilding prep or your weight
loss or whatever you're going for but
once you start getting into higher
intakes it's first of all harder to make
the puzzle work in terms of having
macros that support your health and
performance while including all this
alcohol but also from a molecular
perspective from an endocrine
perspective you are giving yourself a
bit of an uphill battle in that cut now
I do want to mention there's you know
Eric Eric Lee Salazar yeah yeah so
actually I believe last night he became
an IFBB Pro yeah yeah I saw that pretty
wild so now his his arms are ridiculous
they're not normal they're not normal
arms outrageous yeah because what does
he weigh on stage like 140
yeah about 140 I believe his arms look
like he should weigh like 210 I know
it's crazy yeah he challenged the last
time I saw him he challenged me to a
bodybuilding competition and I kept I
kept just trying to shift like the years
down I kept like kicking the can down
the road and I was like well I'm busy
this year give me a year to build and
then a year to maintain and then a year
to cut so I basically talked him back to
like we're probably gonna go head to
head in like 2035 sure and I'm just
gonna assume that by then he's just done
bodybuilding and I'll win by attrition
that's the plan for now but in any case
in his prep this year he was mentioning
that he still has a drink or two from
time to time and I mean like pretty deep
in the prep that I'm not like you know
oh I started prep last week I think I
can squeeze a Miller Lite in he was
having regular full-bodied beers pretty
deep in his prep so it can be done you
just have to be sensible about the dose
to make sure that you're not going to
cause all sorts of chaos when it comes
to muscle signaling and your hormones
yeah I think the important thing to note
is that if you look at the literature
looking at the effects of alcohol on
muscle and body comp things don't look
good but one thing to keep in mind is
most of the studies use a really really
high dose of alcohol they do to see what
happens and and that makes sense from a
scientific perspective because if you're
if you're if you're trying to look at
the effects of something and you have a
limited research budget then ideally if
you can induce a large effect you don't
have to recruit as many subjects and
ultimately it's much more feasible to do
your study it comes out a lot cheaper
but so as a result if you know if one or
two drinks of alcohol does something
it's it's probably a relatively small
effect and
you'd probably need a pretty large
sample size to actually reliably detect
it so for example I know the study that
I see people bandy about on social media
all the time about oh can you have
alcohol after training there was a study
that looked at alcohol versus
carbohydrate versus protein versus
alcohol plus protein on it was either
mTOR signaling or muscle protein
synthesis I think it was muscle protein
synthesis but yeah it found that just
protein without alcohol was best people
did still synthesize some protein with
protein plus alcohol but it was like a
30 40 percent reduction in mps relative
to just the protein condition but the
the part of that study that um that
never gets reported in like Instagram
memes and typically doesn't get reported
when people like write about the study
and I don't mean scientists I mean like
Fitness walkers is what they were
interested in for that study like their
actual research question is whether the
amount of alcohol that athletes would
typically consume after winning a big
game could inhibit recovery and so based
on survey data from I think NC double-a
athletes they the alcohol dose they used
was something like eight to fourteen
standard drinks and so we're talking a
shit-ton alcohol like I mean eight
drinks is a lot eight drinks is a lot
yeah it and when people are like oh can
I have alcohol after training they're
typically thinking a beer or maybe I'm
going out with the lads I'm gonna have
three beers you're typically not
thinking you know after my hard squat
day I'm gonna drink eight shots and then
see if that has a negative impact on
recovery at that point I feel like you
don't even need science
of course taking 8 standard drinks is
going to negatively impact recovery you
know yeah I mean if you struggle to get
out of bed in the morning your
recoveries impaired yeah yeah so yeah I
think the I think the thing to keep in
mind is as with anything else the dose
makes the poison alcohol is a poison
okay that's a literal approach today but
it's a pretty weak poison so you know
low to moderate consumption is probably
not going to have much of a noticeable
effect and really with relatively low
alcohol consumption I would be more
concerned about the effects on sleep
than the direct effects on on like
protein metabolism it's a good point
because even like one or two drinks of
alcohol can negatively impact sleep
quality but yeah I mean you know that's
the thing that really pisses me off like
this is just me whinging about life in
general the two things that I really
would love to have late at night when
I'm winding down I'd love me a good cup
of coffee or I'd love me a nice beer
yeah and like all the research says well
close to bedtime get rid of both of them
and it's like this is all I want in life
and I can't have them yeah it's a it's
garbage really but yeah the the dose
makes the poison as long as you don't
consume much alcohol you'll probably be
fine if you're consuming enough alcohol
that you're worried about your alcohol
consumption it's probably not great yeah
it that is the sleep issue though that's
a good excuse though when someone is
shaming you for having a beer at like
11:00 in the morning and you're like
well I just I'm worried about my sleep
quality I gotta get it in early yeah for
sure that's my story and that's itthat's
evidence-based sure okay question for
Greg here I would like to know what
stage lifter I am if I've been training
consistently for five plus years but I'm
still 15 plus kilos from my genetic
potential according to dr. Casey butts
calculator am I advanced or intermediate
so I don't know nor do I really care I
think that I think that people are too
quick to want to label themselves and
they also probably overstate the
differences between various training
training categories so someone who's
completely untrained that is like a very
different beast than someone who has
some level of training experience you
know you're your first couple of weeks
of lifting you're going to get way more
muscle damage way more Dom's and
soreness than you will it pretty much
any other time in your training career
adaptations occur much faster you're
going to get a lot of rapid strength
gains from neural adaptations and just
from learning the movements that you're
executing in the gym but then I mean
ultimately someone who's been training
for two or three years versus someone
who's been training for ten years it's
really not a night-and-day difference
it's just the person who's been training
for a shorter period of time is probably
just still going to be able to adapt
faster than the person who's been
training for a longer period of time so
if if you wanted to draw a line between
quote-unquote intermediate or
quote-unquote advanced lifters I would
primarily just base it on the rates of
adaptations that the one could
reasonably expect but yeah I mean I just
want to worry about it so it from my
perspective you would only want to be
able to categorize yourself if
categorizing yourself allowed you to to
do something useful with that
information like if that's going to have
a big impact on how you manage your
training for example but I I
don't think I think that the differences
between individuals are dramatically
larger than the mean differences between
quote/unquote intermediate lifters and
quote-unquote advanced lifters so I
think that you should mainly just be
focused on you know not what theoretical
level of lifter I am and therefore how
training should be impacted by that but
more so you know yourself as an
individual and just figuring out what
style of training works best for you as
an individual so yeah
are you advanced or intermediate like I
said I don't know nor nor do I
particularly care and as for being 15
plus kilos from your genetic potential
according to dr. Casey BOTS calculator
yeah take that with a grain of salt I
mean if there was a way to if there was
a way to very reliably predict how much
how much muscle someone would eventually
be able to gain it would be used by
every talent identification program in
existence but there's not and if so the
the Casey buck calculator is based
primarily on frame size I think it's
based on wrist and ankle measurements
which like duh there is research showing
that that is a useful proxy for the
amount of lean mass the frame can carry
but we're talking a very very rough
prediction so whatever whatever that
calculator tells you you could get up to
give it like a 10 15 kilo cushion hits
it's uh it's really only suited for
putting you in the right general
ballpark not giving you a super precise
estimate that you can necessarily expect
to get to during your training career
or necessarily expect to stop at in your
training career like you may get nowhere
close
you may blow it out of the water so yeah
like just don't worry about it like
rather than making long-term predictions
about how much muscle you can gain and
trying to categorize yourself just focus
more on your personal training log and
figuring out what helps you as an
individual make muscle and strength
gains like that's that's what I would
focus on versus you know trying to
forecast where you will eventually end
up ten years down the road I would also
in the least expected move of all time
I'd like to pull this toward the
qualitative sociology research
literature okay I bet you didn't see
that coming Greg I did not because I've
never done that before ever never
so I remember once I was compelled to
read a paper from that field for a class
and it was called the mundanity of
excellence
I think the author's name was Chambliss
he was like a sociologist but he was
studying the practices of elite and sub
elite swimmers basically in the same
kind of team community situation you
know basically in this situation where
everybody's approximately similar
demographically speaking what separates
the elite from the sub elite and the
reason I bring this up is the idea of
equating training time to training
status and what he found was these elite
people they had the same coaching
because they were with the same coaches
they had the same training schedule
their workouts were not these heroic
efforts where they day in and day out
bested the sub elite people they did the
mundane things the normal day-to-day
stuff substantially better and when they
made their qualitative big time leaps in
in their status as a swimmer it was not
doing the same thing harder or more or
for a longer time it was making
meaningful
qualitative changes to what they did and
so I think a lot of times I'm sure
you've seen this Greg you'll see people
who have trained poorly for many years
and they're like well I've been training
for four years I'm not I'm definitely
not a beginner and it's like yeah but
you might be you know what I mean and
some people who jump right in on a
really effective training program
because they're they're in good hands I
mean you can see people make four years
of progress in a year because they just
they cut through all the bullcrap I
started lifting when I was twelve I
sucked it lifting until I was twenty
like so I could have gone into a study
at when I was a freshman and said oh I
qualify for your study I'm definitely a
very advanced lifter I've been lifting
for six years I sucked at lifting I
wasn't strong I was garbage you know so
it's I encourage people first of all to
get away from limiting their ceiling
based on calculations and numbers like
it's interesting information but like
you said you have to figure out a loose
estimate of what you can do shouldn't be
something that limits your ability to
try yeah right and more importantly the
number of years you've been training is
not indicative of how close you are to
your ceiling because you might make
really meaning qualitative meaningful
qualitative changes to how you train
that make they give you big jumps really
big jumps I agree
excellent all right next question for
Eric short and sweet questioned fruits
on contest prep question mark by Shane o
Mac all right
can you consume fruit when you're trying
to get shredded or is that going to just
completely harpoon your diet well I I I
just approved alcohol in prep so I feel
I feel like one might infer that I'm
gonna allow fruit to be on the list as
well but much like alcohol the dose
makes the poison we all know fruits in
large quantity are absolutely going to
kill you but you can eat maybe an apple
once a week is is that where we're going
with this
exactly
an apple a week is a viable approach to
a healthy life that's the saying I think
okay so the glucose and fructose are
different when people talk about can I
have fruit what they're really talking
about generally speaking is can I have
fructose now common misconception not
all of the sugar in fruit is fructose
it's usually a mixture of glucose and
fructose and sometimes other
carbohydrate sources and smaller
quantities as well so the fructose and
glucose are quite different from a
metabolic perspective so glucose is
pretty much metabolized everywhere in
the body fructose on the other hand is
pretty much predominantly metabolized in
the liver specifically so it has a
really big role in replenishing liver
glycogen and creating triglycerides in
the liver as well glucose and fructose
have different effects on insulin
secretion there's a much more pronounced
effect from glucose compared to fructose
they get transported by different
transporters in cell membranes so
glucose largely is transported by glute
1 and glute 4 fructose on the other hand
is transported by glute 5 and even when
you look at glycolysis they the first
couple steps of glycolysis are actually
a little bit different when you compare
glucose to fructose so it's not one of
those things where you can say no it's
totally awash they're exactly the same
you're getting bogged down in minutiae
so from a bio kind of a biochemistry
perspective these are two very different
things with with distinct properties now
on the practical side what do we
actually do with this biochemistry
that's where some of these details
become a little bit less important so
there are studies indicating that if we
really drastically overfeed people with
high fructose intakes we start to see
that fructose is a slightly more
deleterious for certain health outcomes
can
to glucose and what we're really looking
at there is indicators of like
triglycerides liver health fat fat
accumulation in the liver and the
visceral fat component in general so
there are some distinctions and it would
be safe to say hey you probably don't
want to like eat 300 grams of fructose a
day I think that's a very fair thing to
say in terms of just your metabolic
health now where fruit comes into that
is you know practically speaking if
you're eating enough fruit to really
flirt with those levels of fructose
intake your diet is just weird
like honestly it's just a strange diet
like you're talking about getting like a
few hundred grams of carbohydrate from
fruit every day and like just don't do
that just have just have some fruit you
know are you aware of the 30 bananas a
day guy
I think his youtube name is durian
writer I've heard of him yeah man he's a
trip yeah that's like that sort of diet
is the I mean I don't think he's a
full-on Frug of war but that is I think
virtually the only way that you could
you could eat enough fruit for it to
become problematic yeah now I mean you
will find some research saying that once
you start getting to like a hundred
grams a day of fructose and again that's
not total carbs from fruit but 100 grams
of fructose a day then you might start
thinking about making some diet
adjustments but it's really important to
note that most of those studies we're
dealing with people that are generally
overweight or obese but more importantly
or at least equally importantly they're
sedentary
what you find is that the process of
being active and especially doing
rigorous exercise it really works
wonders when it comes to keeping the
liver from a key
all of that fat so I think even if you
are gonna consume a diet that starts
pushing toward that that kind of
borderline number of like a hundred
grams a day of fructose which again is a
ton of fruit I want to reiterate even if
you're getting there if you're like a
lean person that's really active it's
still probably not gonna matter that
much I I do tell people this is my
general saying that I find myself using
more and more and more when you eat
weird amounts of things weird things can
happen so like that doesn't mean fruits
bad but like if you make it your
personal project to see how much fruit a
human could eat weird things could
probably happen you know die either from
a digestive perspective or looking at
the liver with fructose it's generally a
better idea to not eat an objectively
strange diet you know we've had this
whole nutrition science thing going on
for many many decades we probably ought
to use some of what we know we hasn't
been perfect
there have been scapegoats in the
history of nutrition research but you
should generally speaking approximate a
normal human diet when you eat that
that's my extremely evidence-based
recommendation for today but to get
again back to the direct question
you you probably don't need to worry
about it and if you're eating enough
fruit toast from fruit that you do need
to worry about it you already knew that
your diet was pretty it was pretty
atypical you already knew makes sense to
me okay we got a question from James
Walsh a me sure I'd love a discussion
around the benefits of lifting shoes but
with a raised heel what does it do on a
squat versus a leg press I'm thinking
the main difference is to do with the
trunk in the squat question mark so what
do you think about Olympic weightlifting
shoes with an elevated heel for the
squat and for the leg press yeah so
starting starting with the squat
mechanically so kind of just if we
assume humans operate as simple machines
the primary thing the squatting with the
raised heel will do for you is allow
more forward knee travel and allow your
torso to be slightly more upright if you
have ankle mobility restrictions if you
don't have ankle mobility restrictions
theoretically squatting in a flats old
shoe purses a shoe with a raised heel
should be virtually identical and so so
in terms of who I would pretty strongly
recommend to at least try squatting with
a raised heel it would primarily be
people with ankle mobility restrictions
like I said that's if we assume that
humans are just simple machines
something to note though is that much
like in a previous episode we talked
about how a small difference in cueing
or just a very small change in
positioning for a lift can subjectively
make it feel quite different either a
lot stronger or just subjectively feel a
lot better and more comfortable I think
that same principle applies when we're
talking about lifting shoes so it is not
uncommon for a lifter to like habitually
squat in in one kind of shoe put on
another kind of shoe you take a video of
the squat squat looks basically the same
but one just feels way way better or way
way worse
so even if the even if you don't have
ankle mobility restrictions and your
squat kinematically is is virtually
identical with a flat sole shoe versus a
raised heel you may still strongly
prefer one to the other and so I do
think that even if there's not something
that looks like it should be an obvious
benefit I still think it's worth most
lifters playing around with with
squatting with a raised heel just to see
if like anecdotally for themselves that
feels better
and then for squat versus leg press so
Eric and I were talking about this
before we started recording because
while I do have some raised heel squat
shoes
I never leg press uh-huh or I haven't
leg pressed consistently and probably a
decade so I don't think I've ever worn
my squat shoes on a leg press
but what Eric said made a lot of sense
and he said it basically just depends on
the angle of the leg press platform so
some leg presses if you're like before
you start going down your ankles will
basically be in neutral like you know
you're the angle of your foot coming off
of your shank will be like 90 degrees
and in that case wearing a shoe with an
elevated heel will likely allow for
greater depth on the leg press and more
forward knee travel again if you do have
ankle mobility restrictions but then a
lot of leg presses the the platform that
your feet rest on are already angled so
even with a flat sole shoe it gives you
the effect of as if you were already
wearing a raised heel and in that
situation you're kind of stacking a
raised heel on top of a faux raised heel
just from the leg press platform and it
can feel like like pressing in high
heels and just generally feel weird and
and I guess theoretically could like
hyperextend your ankle like probably not
enough to hurt it but enough to put it
in kind of a weird and uncomfortable
range of motions
yeah I think for the like press it it
kind of kind of depends on how the leg
press you use is built and specifically
the angle of the platform yeah I mean it
gets a little uncomfortable sometimes
because it's like you're starting the
leg press with a reasonable amount of
plantar flexion at the ankle and yeah
you almost feel like you're pushing over
the platform then through it and once
once you get to a certain level of
plantar flexion it's a very
uncomfortable feeling if there's like a
severe angle on that but if it's nice
and flat it it feels very similar to
just squatting in a in an elevated heel
that makes sense
all right so next question for Eric I
will say we don't typically shame people
who ask us questions but if Eric chooses
to shame our next question asker I
wouldn't necessarily blame him for it
and and once you dear listener hear this
question you'll understand why
so know for for the sake of his own
privacy and pride
I will leave out the questioners name
but the question is how do I prevent my
traps from getting too big so I'm not
going to shame this this listener it's a
wasted opportunity no it's so I always
take the approach of empathy and
understanding and I have asked this
question myself way back in the day so I
was getting ready for my first ever
bodybuilding competition and a local gym
owner was helping me out getting
prepared and I didn't know anything and
I thought I was very muscular it turns
out in hindsight I was what you would
call obese but that's the thing what the
doctors were telling me him look at work
were you at least fuss Keeler yeah I
think that's fair yeah but I expected to
look like Flex Lewis by the time I got
lean and turns out I had a lot of fat on
me
I didn't know that but anyway so I go to
the gym and I'm learning how to pose and
all that stuff and I'm like you know my
traps are really overpowering this
physique how do I make sure that they
that I keep those in check maybe
minimize their their prominence in the
physique in the interest of symmetry
back in those days I basically saw
myself as what's-his-name eight timer
Lee Haney Haney yeah in my own mind I
was essentially Lee Haney in terms of
symmetry so sure and the guy that was
helping me out was far too nice to say
it this way but essentially the response
was listen Eric if we do a physique
audit right now you have all bad muscle
groups if you allow the traps to make to
overpower your physique now you have one
good muscle group so I think we ought to
just play the numbers and keep the one
good muscle group so that was my I I
really do tell bodybuilders though
especially early in their career dude if
it's growing grow it yeah just grow it
it will build everything else around it
in time but the idea that you're you
know if you're like kind of early in the
career and you're like I don't know I
want to be symmetrical no forget about
symmetry for now get huge we'll deal
with that later now I will say this for
people who aren't bodybuilders or power
lifters or strongmen or whatever there
are people who just aesthetically are
like oh I don't like the way my physique
looks when my blank is over developed so
you know some people might not want huge
lats or I mean I understand that that's
subjective aesthetic preference I'm just
saying that it's a dumb subjective
aesthetic right that's that's my pretty
so here's my ode to traps a lot of the
people that folks think are are super
jacked like in film and on TV aren't
even that jacked they just have huge
traps like if you want a shortcut to
everyone thinking that you're like way
more muscular than you
actually our get big traps and get big
forearms like though those are the two
things that I think people in a thick
neck doesn't hurt either but those are
the things that I think people just
subconsciously evaluate and if you have
huge traps huge forearms thick neck
they're like okay this guy's [ __ ]
jacked I don't want to mess with him I
think the prime example of that is Tom
Hardy as bane in the Dark Knight Rises
if you at some point when Bane's on
screen and not when he's wearing his big
coat but you know something sometime
when it's sun's out guns out just pause
it
evaluate Tom Hardy's physique he's not
that bigger muscular but Tom Hardy has
enormous traps and so as soon as Bane
comes on the screen you're like oh [ __ ]
that guy's [ __ ] huge and like if you
take a second to evaluate you know he's
muscular but he's not huge but the traps
just connect to some primal part of your
brain and it makes you think it's like a
it's like a lion's mane or or like the
[ __ ] toad the that blows its the sack
under its chin up to look bigger it's
it's like that type of thing like as you
always say the lizard part of your brain
yeah yes do it yeah it it just hits you
right in the lizard part of your brain
and immediately makes you think that
person is huge so whatever people can
have different aesthetic preferences but
if you're someone who wants to be
perceived as a large muscular person
your traps cannot be too big like that
that is getting bigger traps should be
them the main focus of your training
honestly in your life yeah in a way now
I will say this I do have a
straightforward solution because we're
here to help the people Greg don't
forget if you want to avoid developing
your traps then certainly you're gonna
have to get creative with your exercise
selection and make sure that you're
choosing exercise variations that don't
load the traps directly so you know if
you want to be like I mean if you're
dead lifting and dead lifting and dead
lifting it's gonna be hard to avoid some
kind of trap stimulus from that but you
know that that would be the only really
useful advice would be you'll just have
to choose exercise variations that that
very clearly don't load the traps
directly but don't tell Gregg that you
made that choice find all right Gregg
question for you I'm gonna use a little
bit of creative license here to to
rephrase it so Mika asked fiber type
differentiation as consequence of a
specific stimulus I'm thinking the
question there is can you intentionally
train for a shift in fiber type is that
how you interpret that yeah yeah I think
I think that's I think that's what meek
is asking so yes you can and it's well
you you can to some extent so this
question the aunt this answer catches a
lot of people off-guard in probably less
so now since Andy Galvin is pretty
well-known at this point but if you if
you took an anatomy and physiology class
at any point during the last 20 years
you probably learned that fiber type
interconversion between type 2 a and
type 2 X fibers is possible and happens
all the time
but you probably also learned that fiber
type interconversion between type 1 and
type 2 fibers doesn't really happen or
if it does happen it's only under very
extreme circumstances so for example
with aging type 2 motor nerve
can die and then offshoots of type one
motor nerves can re innervate those
prior type ii fibers and then they
become type 1 fibers but that that's
kind of a somewhat extreme case so but
but you you probably learn that just
from normal day to day exercise training
you don't get interconversion of type 1
and type 2 fibers so what we now know is
that we thought that mainly due to
pretty crude methods of identifying
fibers so it would primarily just be
taking a muscle biopsy cutting it
cutting a cross-section of it staining
it and then based on how dark or how
light those stain fibers showed up as
just identifying them as type 1 type 2a
or type 2 x fibers and putting them
neatly into those three categories there
is a much more time-consuming but a much
better method of quantifying fiber types
where you you basically take single
fibers and use gel electrophoresis to be
able to quantify the percentage of
different myosin heads within that
muscle fiber and then you do that for a
slew of fibers and that gives you a
better idea of the spectrum of fiber
types an individual has and that gives
us the insight that there are hybrid
fiber types so you have some fibers that
all of the myosin heads are type 1 you
have some fibers where all of the myosin
heads are type 2a and most people don't
have true type 2 X fibers where all of
the myosin heads within the fiber or
type 2 X but some people have a
smattering of them but then especially
for untrained athletes you have a lot of
hybrid fibers where you know maybe in
one file
70% of the myosin heads are type 2 a 30%
or type 1 and another fiber maybe it's
70% type 1 30% type 2a or a hybrid
between 2a + 2 X where you know some of
the myosin heads are 2a myosin some of
them are 2 X and then you can either
even have hybrids that have type 1
myosin heads type 2 a and type 2 X so
hybrid fibers are a thing and there is
so one of the hallmarks of training is
that you basically lose hybrid fibers
and you lose them in the direction that
you train for the most part so you know
let's say you have just to make let's
just assume type 2 X fibers don't exist
for a second just to make this
illustration easy let's say pre-training
you have 40% pure type 1 fibers 40% pure
type 2a fibers and 20% type 1 type 2 a
hybrid fibers if you do aerobic training
then those hybrid fibers will shift and
become pure type 1 fibers such that
after a fair amount of training it would
look something pretty close to 60% type
1 40% type 2a with very very few hybrid
fibers if you D trained again it would
probably go back to 40 40 20 type 1 type
2 a and hybrid if instead you did
resistance training or some sort of
anaerobic training like like heavy
anaerobic training so like weightlifting
strongman probably throwing stuff like
that it would shift the other direction
such that you would wind up with 40
percent type 1 60 percent type 2 a and
very very few hybrids so having a lot of
hybrid fibers is kind of a hallmark of
being a very low training status and
just being pretty sedentary for the most
part and trained athletes
so I don't know I don't know and I don't
even know how you would study weather
like a pure type to a fiber could become
a pure type one fiber I I don't even
know how you would quantify that but
what we do know is you can get very
substantial fiber type differentiation
within those hybrid fibers based on how
you train and another thing is if you do
have any type 2 X fibers they pretty
much just go away with training I
remember learning in xf-- is that doing
power training would cause a fiber type
interconversion from type 2 a to type 2
X my professor that taught me that
wasn't really a muscle physio I don't
know that he was basing that on any
evidence I think he may have just
assumed that's how it works that's how
he taught us but if you learned
something similar that doesn't really
happen there there is some research that
if you do pretty low volume power
training you can better preserve type 2
X myosin heads within your muscle fibers
but I don't necessarily know that that's
a beneficial thing but yeah for the most
part your proportion of type 2 X myosin
heads goes down with training regardless
of what type of training you do and
those hybrids get interconverted or get
converted primarily to either pure type
1 or pure type 2 a in the direction of
the type of training you do so if you do
resistance training you'll mostly get
conversion of hybrid fiber types to type
2a fibers if you mostly do aerobic
endurance training you'll mostly get
conversion of those hybrid fibers to
type 1 fibers I have a follow-up
question sure
so if this conversion can occur due to
training do you think it matters do you
think it's something that we ought to
intentionally train for or do you see it
as a consequence of training
yeah I see it as a consequence of
training I mean so you you wouldn't tell
somebody to go out and say you should
train like this so that you convert
these fibers no I mean the direction of
the fiber type conversions kind of makes
sense like yeah if you if you want to be
an endurance athlete
you probably want more type one myosin
heads within within your muscle fibers
and so just doing endurance training
will give you that adaptation and you
don't specifically have to do a
specialized form of endurance training
to calls that adaptation and same would
apply for type two a myosin heads and
resistance training so yeah I don't I
don't I I can't think of a situation
where you would need to train for that
adaptation that would be outside of the
normal training you would want to do for
whatever other types of adaptations
you're aiming for yeah
can I take a moment to brag really quick
yeah you mentioned learning undergrad X
phys muscle physiology did I ever tell
you about who I learned muscle
physiology from No
so he was the PI on several studies
looking at myostatin inhibition starting
with ronan models then working up to
primate models and at the time that I
was in that class which was about 10
years ago he was actually gearing up to
do a human trial on myostatin inhibition
when he talked about muscle it was just
so fascinating like I would show up to
that class like 15 minutes early to get
the best seat it was so cool that's
awesome I never I never ended up
checking in to see if that human trial
got off the ground or what what the
results were though I needed to check
that out some day should do that so man
I'm gonna pull an Eric and butcher this
name it's it's Jeff something it's a
Jeff oh I en I think that might be the
Irish spelling of Ian I think this might
be Jeff Ian but
I could be completely wrong about that
anyway
the question is protein refractory
period : if you agree with the theory
will eating a snack with protein in it
in our after a meal disrupt protein
synthesis if there's another meal an
hour to after that hope that makes sense
okay so I want to reference someone here
but I don't know how to say his name
tromelin how do you say his first name
Dorn yarn I believe so I knew it
couldn't be joined it'd be too simple
it'd be way too simple I honestly dude
I'm pretty sure that I'm pretty sure
that he's Dutch so like should I know
that you know no if we if we butcher the
name the only the only possible
consequences that we piss off more Dutch
people which I feel like at this point
that bridge is burned yeah I thought
you're gonna say we should blacklist him
like nope no Dutch people on the show
that's it no we we can be the
magnanimous parties in this in this
period of gearing up for war like we
will probably eventually end up waging
war with the Netherlands but we don't
want it to be said that we didn't
attempt to extend an olive branch and be
the magnanimous party yeah we will be be
the bigger people we will be above the
feud and we'll still acknowledge good
work where it's been done kureta yeah so
your has written about this quite a few
times one was on stronger by science
stronger by science calm slash athlete
protein intake
he also wrote something about it on his
site I believe it's his site called
nutrition tactics yeah
dot-com and which I'll just say is a
great site yeah if you're interested in
muscle protein synthesis just google
nutrition tactics complete guide to
muscle protein synthesis it's it's the
best and most thorough lay article
you're going to find out there it's it's
really really good work yeah so I mean
you're an I mean this is his thing he
loves muscle protein synthesis
specifically as it pertained
two people that resisted train so he's
put he has put a lot of really good
information out there now the concept of
the protein refractory period is based
on some research I believe mostly done
in mice showing that we give a meal
muscle protein synthesis is spiked
assuming that it's a meal that delivers
a decent amount of leucine and you know
a complete amino acid profile so we get
a spike in muscle protein synthesis and
then for some period of time there's
what we call refractoriness where
another bolus of protein isn't quite
enough to establish another spike in
protein synthesis it's like you initiate
it and then you essentially have to wait
to fully initiate that a second time and
so you know the general takeaway from
that line of research has been that you
should separate your protein meals
throughout the day and I think most
people generally say three to five hours
between meals and to kind of clear that
refractory period that a lot of people
say is probably about three hours give
or take now your wrote about that and he
brought up a really good point that when
you introduce resistance training into
that picture things look a little bit
different and so I know he specifically
referenced a study by a church ward then
in 2012 and what they found was that for
because resistance training causes such
a robust and pronounced increase in
muscle protein synthesis and a
heightened sensitivity to the initiation
of protein synthesis what he found was
basically that because that effect
persists for so long after the
resistance training bout this whole
refractoriness concept seemed a little
bit less critical it basically you know
a the takeaway that your and arrived at
and that he very convincingly very
convincingly kind of paints the picture
for is that if you're a resistant strain
person it still probably makes sense to
split your meals up in some logical
but it probably doesn't make a lot of
sense to get too bogged down in the
details of timing meals down to the
minute or the hour so I think the
general recommendation would be and this
is the exact recommendation I give my
clients you want to have it preferably
three to five meals that contain a
decent bolus of high-quality protein and
if you can't get a high quality protein
then you need to match some low quality
proteins to make that work but three to
five protein meals throughout the day
spaced relatively equidistant but
without giving yourself a headache
trying to get bogged down in too many
details but I mean if you're a
resistance trained person you know
you're stimulating protein synthesis all
over the place have high quality protein
at least a good twenty or thirty gram
dose at least three times a day
three to five should be fine I think
that's about as technical as you really
need to get when it comes to timing
protein what do you think reg I mean
that makes sense to me I think that one
area so I think that the protein timing
stuff is interesting but one thing I'll
note is that the the the best long-term
studies we have on the effects of what
would be considered sub optimal protein
timing patterns on actual changes in
performance and body composition are
probably grant tensley's - time
restricted feeding studies where
basically they have people consuming all
of their food within an eight hour time
window instead of spread throughout the
day as someone typically would and both
of those studies older one in men and
more recent one in women found that that
didn't seem to compromise changes in
performance or changes in body
composition which with resistance
training which leads me to believe that
not not that protein timing doesn't
matter at all but that it's maybe even
less important than we even previously
thought that that if it does have an
effect it's probably a very very small
one if that effect I mean so let me be
clear like protein timing does matter on
some level so you know maybe eating all
of your protein within an eight hour
time window versus a sixteen hour time
window doesn't make much of a difference
but if say you only consumed protein
once per week even if you matched for
weekly protein intake that probably
ain't good but yeah I think that it's
probably much more lenient than we
previously thought and the thing is like
if someone's going to make a hard
argument for protein timing making a
really big difference there they're
going to be primarily relying on acute
studies looking at short-term changes in
muscle protein synthesis but like I said
grant tensley's two studies on time
restricted feeding with resistance
training is probably the best like
actual longitudinal evidence that we
have so that that's probably what I
would hang my hat more on personally I
agree and grant is awesome by the way
terrific guy really good researcher his
most recent paper that you're referring
to
if you've read through it is really well
done oh yeah really it's really good
really good it doesn't look like an
exercise science paper and I mean that
in all the best ways but you know what I
mean right yeah yeah you can tell but
anyway it the thing that I think people
miss on this conversation like I was
alluding to earlier grant has done these
studies and resistance trained people
and resistance training with a decent
program is such a robust stimulus for
protein synthesis that lasts for such a
long period of time I think it probably
buys us a little bit of legal
when it comes to to protein timing yeah
yeah I also think people overlook the
fact that like even the the basic
recommendation I gave right so three to
five protein meals at least three hours
apart three or four hours apart I mean
if you have an an hour feeding window
you you could meet that criteria very
easily I mean if you're eating it you
eat a meal at noon 4 p.m. 8 p.m.
mm-hmm you just did intermittent fasting
you had three you know three large
bonuses of protein for hours apart so
you know I think people sometimes forget
that intermittent fasting if you're
looking at it as an eight hour feeding
window is not a particularly restrictive
window in terms of meeting those basic
guidelines and even if you take a more
extreme approach it's like oh well I
recommended three and you only got two
that's not a huge diversion even if
you're going down to like a 4-hour
feeding window mm-hmm so it's it's not
that extreme of an approach so yeah I if
I had to lead someone in one direction
or the other of are you gonna really
stress over protein timing or just say
screw it I'll eat when I'm hungry I
would almost lead toward this screw it
I'll eat when I'm hungry cuz it just
doesn't seem to be the type of thing
that you should lose a lot of sleep over
I agree all right so we talked a little
bit about hormones with the alcohol
question now we've got another one from
Penn Tarleton what are the chronic
effects of resistance training on
hormone levels man so that's a good
question and the answer frustratingly is
it depends so we don't have we don't
have the type of longitudinal evidence
that I would want to make generalized
statements most most of what we do have
that's out there is kind of we take
people who are untrained we put
resistance training program and we
measure their hormone levels
you know pre training and then after
four months of training or something
like that but the question you then have
to ask yourself is was the training
program they were put on for that study
a valid archetype for all resistance
training you know and I would I would
argue probably not and then also you
know would there be any adaptations
between you know four months of training
and five years of training maybe I don't
know so I I don't think we we have a
really good idea about that one thing
that does seem pretty consistent is that
resistance training decreases myostatin
levels that's probably one of the things
that is permissive for muscle
hypertrophy that does seem to be a
pretty consistent hormonal adaptation
there was a a reasonably long-term study
on weight lifters I want to say I want
to say they they just had people go
about their normal training and just
took blood samples maybe a like Year
Zero and like year five or something
like that
that found slight increases in
testosterone levels but probably not
enough to really really hang your hat on
but one of one of the things to keep in
mind is that most most hormones in your
body are under some sort of negative
feedback loop and the primary things
that would be influencing levels of
those hormones would not be resistance
training or at least like the chronic
effects of resistance training so so
like acutely you know you do some
resistance training you're gonna have
huge spikes and catecholamine levels
epinephrine norepinephrine but that
doesn't necessarily mean that that's
going to chronic
change your baseline catecholamine
levels so so other than the the decrease
in myostatin I don't feel confident
enough about any other hormonal changes
that I would feel good saying that like
yes this is a thing that happens and
it's consistent enough that you can bank
on it and it and it probably largely
depends on your training dose as well so
it seems like you know moderate levels
of training probably don't have a huge
impact on hormone levels but obviously
overtraining does or especially like
pretty high levels of training with
pretty low energy intake causing
relative energy deficiency that that has
impacts on a lot of hormones but can you
necessarily say that's due to chronic
effects of resistance training or is
that due to you know excessive
resistance training with low energy
intake like I I wouldn't want to
attribute that solely to resistance
training so yeah other than other than
the this the decrease in myostatin I
don't feel confident enough about the
other changes that have been reported in
studies to to really throw that out
there as changes that one should
necessarily expect with resistance
training do you have any input on that
Eric I have nothing valuable to add cool
just like normal okay um so next
question for Eric I just want to remind
you you are a temporary guest host so
yeah I'm pushing my luck today I'm
feeling uh feeling a little sassy yeah
okay we'll work on that
next question from Nick watch a I'm
going to assume what are the best
strategies to reverse the effects of
metabolic adaptation from a fat loss
phase while minimizing fat gain smiling
emoji simplest question but I love
hearing it discussed praise
emoji yes so I wrote an article on
metabolic adaptation for the site I
think it was what like 22,000 words
there abouts yeah so it might have
actually been more than that but I I'm
going to challenge myself to be concise
here so if you want the full every
thought I've ever had on the topic it is
in writing an accessible for free
anytime but to answer this question so
we're talking about metabolic adaptation
there are essentially two distinct
components that contribute to metabolic
adaptation the first would be the short
term acute energy deficit so just the
day-to-day not having enough calories to
make ends meet right now
the other component is the more
long-term loss of fat storage so
basically your body being a biological
entity realizing that over time you've
been working at a deficit for a while
and all that energy that you had saved
up is running pretty low so these are
both inputs that generally speaking feed
into the hypothalamus which initiates
this whole mess that we call metabolic
adaptation so the question is we do this
fat loss phase and let's say we do it
right and at the end of it we're pretty
damn lean and probably not eating a lot
of calories so how do we try to reverse
some of those things and recover from
the diet without putting on all the fat
that we just gained I'd like to say that
there's an easy way that you get your
total energy expenditure right back to
normal without gaining fat and all your
hormones go back to normal
but I don't think I can promise you that
there are some useful things that we can
do step one is doing the diet itself
well and so some key things there first
of all it's always nice if you don't dig
a big hole to climb out of ok so if you
have an ideal body weight in mind the
ideal situation is that during your
weight gain phase you don't get too far
away from it when we start to see really
huge overall magnitudes of weight loss
it makes the it makes the process a bit
challenging as you would imagine another
thing is having it an appropriate rate
of weight loss so somewhere between a
half a percent to a percent of body
weight per week is usually a comfortable
rate of weight loss that ensures that
you don't have to have an enormous
deficit and that you don't lose your
body weight at a rate that is likely to
threaten your performance threaten
excessive drops in hormone levels and
threaten the loss of lean mass you want
to do resistance training and have a
sensible diet a sensible size deficit
throughout the weight loss if you can
there's some new research showing that
diet breaks or kind of multiple-day
refeeds might be helpful in attenuating
metabolic adaptation on the way down
to your ideal weight the the I would say
probably the most solid evidence is
implementing a two week diet break every
two weeks so two weeks of dieting and
two weeks of maintenance and it's really
important a diet break is not taking a
break from the diet and just eating
whatever you want it is a controlled
period of time where you eat exactly at
maintenance and then throughout the diet
you want to make sure you have a decent
macronutrient split and you don't overdo
your cardio now after the diet what can
we do you'll want to gain some weight
right out of the gate to facilitate
recovery assuming that you got really
really lean now if you didn't get really
really lean if you if you just got to
like a pretty sustainable body fat level
then you actually probably can bypass
that step because you're probably not
hurting too bad in the metabolic
adaptation department but what you'll
want to do is is start increasing
caloric intake and you want to stay
active during that process when you look
at the research of who really does a
good job sustaining weight loss they
have two characteristics the first thing
is that they track things well they
diligently track their body weight their
caloric intake things like that the
other thing is that they stay active
non-exercise activity
exercise activity when you let those
fall off you you start really working
against your goals in this regard so you
basically want to just commit to a small
but consistent surplus you don't want to
be all over the place where you're
overeating and binge eating some days
and then trying to correct and
overcorrect and and have days where
you're in a pretty sizable deficit you
want to train hard to try to promote as
much muscle growth as you can during
that time period it's going to be hard
people that are weight reduced if they
start gaining any weight it tends to
preferentially be fat mass so the ways
we offset that is we try to commit to a
small but consistent caloric surplus an
effective resistance training program
with a high-protein diet
try to stay active even when you're
outside of the gym and for now that's
about the best we can do did I miss out
on any key things Gregg nothing that's
immediately coming to mind it sucks I
mean unfortunately the weight
maintenance the numbers aren't great
it's hard to do because you get down to
a body weight and you can you can't get
away with eating the same calories you
used to you have to be really diligent
about keeping your activity level up you
have to meticulously track things you
have to stay on it now over time I do
think from a behavioral perspective it
gets a little easier and more manageable
I don't think that I mean if you were 40
pounds over your ideal weight you were
probably you probably had a lot of
activity and eating behaviors that were
conducive to maintaining that extra 40
pounds of weight so a lot of people want
to get in a situation where now they're
at their ideal body weight but
everything else is the same they go back
to their normal eating activity habits
that they used to have I I really don't
think that's gonna happen for the
overwhelming majority of people and I
think that's something that takes a lot
of wrestling with and you kind of have
to get to the point where you're
comfortable accepting that I think it
doesn't mean every day is gonna be an
absolute grind and you're gonna feel
like you're starving your whole life but
it's yet you have to make some pretty
meaningful
behavioral changes and some adjustments
to how you interact with food and how
you view your activity level if that
makes sense it makes sense to me okay oh
this is a fun one so we've got a
question here to wrap things up from 81
NC 19 that's great so to help me with
the name recognition if you could just
make it a very easy alphanumeric code
that would be extremely helpful moving
forward so even on Facebook go ahead and
change your facebook name make it an
alphanumeric code like that so the
question is what exercises are overrated
and should be eliminated part two of the
question which exercises are underrated
and need more attention overrated
exercises oh I'm gonna start with a
spicy one if you're not a power lifter I
think bench press is overrated I think
that the the freedom of movement that
you can get from dumbbells is probably a
better option the biggest drawback to
dumbbells is it's probably not a great
idea to go for a 1 rep max dumbbell
press but unless you're a power lifter
you don't necessarily need to know your
one rep max is in the first place but
yeah it's um like dumbbell bench is a
lot more joint friendly for a lot of
people because you can do it with a a
quasi neutral grip which which I have
found helps a lot of people who have
either elbow or shoulder issues like I
said you have more freedom over the
range of motion for most people it the
dumbbell press movement of your hands
just feels more natural than your hands
being locked in a given position like X
distance from your shoulders for for the
entire press and you can also just
pretty easily get a longer range of
motion if you want for a lot of people
that doesn't matter but especially for
people with relatively big chests bench
press is like
partial range of motion exercise which
is perfectly fine if you're a power
lifter and minimizing range of motion
helps you be good at your sport but if
you're just training for general
strength and muscle development it's
probably not a great thing so yeah I
think that uh and I'm certainly not
saying bench press is a bad exercise but
the fact that it is like the exercise
that most people in the gym care about I
think that again it's not bad but I
would say it is substantially overrated
would it be controversial to suggest
that like essentially all calf training
is overrated that is that's very
controversial and I'll fight you over
that calf training is the best
why do you say when's the last time you
trained calves two days ago really hell
yeah I love calf training dude I've
taken months off of calf training and I
have not seen it this is probably saying
more about me than calf training but I
have not seen any change in my calf size
from like six months of D training well
I mean if if we think about muscle
hypertrophy versus maintenance we know
that it takes way less stimulus to
maintain adaptations than to accrue them
in the first place
and since you walk around day to day I
mean your calves are probably getting
adequate stimulus to maintain whatever a
muscle you built so I don't think not
losing calf size is evidence of calf
training being worthless I think that
just shows that walking around day to
day is an adequate level of stimulus to
maintain whatever you built
okay so build up some cath mass and then
it then it's useless then just walk
around all day but that's my modified
hot take sure but calf training is so
fun it's not fun - it feels great are
you kidding me dude I have an e-version
ankle sprain from my wrestling days that
my ankle is still just a mess from it
yeah what do you your ankle fell off
yeah how are you doing that uh I mean
like I can even move your ankle how are
you doing calf training
loading up a bunch of weight is the only
way that that ankle can go into
dorsiflexion and so so I have really
[ __ ] up ankles for anyone listening I
think the reason I like calf training so
much is it's the only way that I can
stretch my my calves and ankles out to
make them feel good my body weight is
insufficient to to cross my body or to
cause my calves to go into into
dorsiflexion so getting on something
like a leg press and loading up like
four or five hundred pounds gives me
enough force to actually go into to
dorsiflexion and stretch my calves out
man it feels good and just for context I
mean your ankle your foot fell off you
had a basketball injury yeah it just
everything broken tore am i spent a
bystander vomited from seeing it
correctly yeah I had a compound tib-fib
fracture and when I stood up my my foot
was pointed the wrong direction so yeah
my left ankle is pretty pretty worthless
at this point I will say for a less-hot
take of overrated exercises I've gotten
away from doing the barbell military
press and I've moved more toward
unilateral dumbbell pressing overhead it
almost like a circus dumbbell press
mm-hmm and I've found that it might be
because I have one shoulder that's great
and one that's terrible but the
unilateral approach to me feels so much
more natural you know I'm standing not
against a back pad so the scapula and
the glenohumeral joint can kind of move
with their natural synchronicity between
them I've got a lot of my clients
switching over from the traditional
military press to single single arm
overhead pressing how do you feel about
that no I can see that that uh that
makes a lot of sense and a lot of a lot
of people that aren't really into
overhead pressing really struggle with
clearing the chin and then kind of
getting back under the bar on the on the
mill
Terry prayer yeah yeah any underrated
exercises so that we're not just
completely bashing things and being
negative all day um I think single-leg
Rd ELLs are great um I was gonna say
that
god damn it okay how about you explain
oh I have a different one I have a
different oh man I was gonna say you can
expand on that and I'll come up with
another one yeah I think single like Rd
ELLs are great
I think they so most the the vast
majority of the people who I have had
tryout single-leg Rd ELLs who come from
any sort of strength sports background
and primarily here I'm thinking mostly
powerlifting and a few weight lifters so
our sports are very bilateral like
squatting is a bilateral exercise
deadlifting is a bilateral exercise
there's some level of asymmetry if you
do like a split jerk but you know for
the most part cleans snatches bilateral
exercise and I think that a lot of
people wind up with like the hip
extensors on one leg being considerably
stronger than the other and the range of
motion in their hips differing a pretty
fair amount and here I'm thinking like a
adduction and an internal rotation range
of motion and so a lot of times when
people try single like rdls for the
first time they'll notice that the
movement feels pretty easy on one leg
they can you know whatever implement
they're lifting they can take it all the
way down to the floor without much of an
issue control is good they get on to the
other leg and just balancing on that leg
feels fine but then once they get into I
don't know maybe 40 degrees of hip
flexion then it just all starts falling
apart and the range of motion is way
worse the control is way worse
strength through like the upper part of
the range of
is pretty good but once they start
getting into deeper hip flexion one hip
is way weaker than the other and so I
think single like Rd ELLs one are a good
exercise to like equally strengthen your
hip extensors on both sides like I think
that you get a good training effect from
it and I think it's a good exercise for
shining a magnifying glass on strength
imbalances you may have to be clear I'm
not saying that in a context of oh if
you're you know three percent
asymmetrical you're going to get injured
because I I think that's how a lot of
people think about asymmetries I'm only
worried about asymmetry insofar as if
you have a major strength deficit or a
major movement deficit on one side of
your body that could be negatively
affecting your performance so I'm
thinking about this purely from a
performance perspective not like a
injury perspective but yeah I think that
boat both has didn't exercise for
actually training your hip extensors and
as kind of a diagnostic tool
single leg are deals are absolutely
fantastic yeah I've been doing a ton of
those lately I've been doing with it
with a dumbbell or a kettlebell I
haven't gotten into the barbell too much
with those but that'll be down the road
once I get a little more comfort with it
my underrated exercise is for the
physique oriented folks out there when
you think a lat development you know
everybody's doing a million kinds of
rows a million kinds of pull downs and
pull ups the straight arm pull down I
think is a very underrated exercise for
lat development and if you're fortunate
enough there's the old school Hammer
Strength pullover machine oh hell yeah
that is only found in like the dungeon
gyms and then just like you'll bump into
it randomly and you'll be like how did
this get here
but that machine is so clutch but it
should be mandatory in all commercial
gyms so clutch for that development
absolutely love it you it is an ungodly
lat pump that cannot be read
located no I agree I I've I don't think
I've ever used the original machine but
I've used that type of machine in one of
the gyms that I used to train at maybe
five years ago had that machine and yeah
like I do very little direct lat
training but that machine just felt so
good I still found a way to use it like
two or three times a week yeah all right
well I think that does it for this
episode thanks for listening and we will
see you next time thanks for listening
to the stronger by science podcast now
Greg and I are not experts in medicine
or health or really anything else for
that matter so before you make any
changes to your diet and exercise habits
make sure you check with a doctor or
another health care professional if you
enjoyed this podcast and you'd like to
support it visit stronger by science
comm to check out the products and
services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
you